[Music]
did you see my tax by the way I did yeah
he's out a pretty badass
yeah a four year old of friend of mine
as a four year old daughter and she came
up to me and she said lie down I'll give
you tattoos and so I did and she gave me
these tats she applied these tattoos to
my arm that night I went with my wife to
a restaurant there's like two nights ago
and we went we sitting at the bar and
this much was peeking out just literally
that much was peeking out and the
bartender had all these tattoos and he
he saw I mean he saw that I got some
kind of tattoo and he just was like hey
man nice tat nice time
he said where'd you get it I said I got
it in the Navy and he was like wow
pretty cool and they went yeah check it
out
[Applause]
and the crazy thing is they won't come
off I showered like 9th I know that
little this little kitty Hello Kitty and
her little bit of power and she start
that's pretty right let's go kick that
guy's ass oh no check those tats let's
leave him alone he's he's from the Hello
Kitty gang